[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال الاختيار افتحلوها
بادرس العمل
مهددا الخيار العسكري ضد ايران مطروح اذا
فشل المسار الدبلوماسي
ايران تردوا على تصريحات اوكرانيا من هجوم
اصفهان بانها ستغير موقفها من الحرب لصالح
روسيا
الاسود
من الابتعاد عن حل الدولتين كونه سيضر
بامن اسرائيل مستقبلا
بل
حاله طوارئ عالميه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا سابدا بهذا الخبر العاجل الذي
ورد قبل قليل الشرطه البلجيكيه اصابه شخص
بجروح بسكين بعد هجوم في محطه لمترو
الانفاق في بروكسل كم اعلنت الشرطه انها
اعتقلت المجتمع به ولا تزال تبحث في
الدوافع
كوشي كوشي كوشي
[موسيقى]
الاوليه لعمليه الطعن التي حصلت في مترو
الانفاق في بروكسيل وتم اعتقال الشخص الذي
قام بهذه العمليه
ومن ادى الى اصابه شخص بجروح وهي يعني
عمليه لم تعطي الشرطه حتى الساعه اي
تفاصيل عنها وما هي الدوافع التي ادت الى
هذه العمليه المزيد من التفاصيل معي من
بروكسيل نور الدين مراسل العربيه نور
الدين هل من تفاصيل اضافيه عن هذه العمليه
يبدو ان ال المتهم او المتهم بهذه العمليه
قد حاول الاعتداء على
المسافرين في احدى عربات مترو محطه المترو
تسمى
شومان وهي حيث توجد طبعا فوق سطحها مقرات
الاتحاد الاوروبي المفوضيه المجلس مجلس
الوزراء همم القمه الاوروبيه يبدو ان
المتهم قد حاول داخل همم وعلى رصيف او عند
الخروج من عربه همم المترو مترو الانفاق
ثم همم فرع همم من خلال درجات المصعد حيث
اعتقدته الشرطه في الطابق الاول ثم اغلقت
المحبه في هذه الحدث التي نتحدث فيها
اليكم الشرطه اغلقته هناك سيارات
لرجال الامن لا يسمح بالدخول او الاقتراب
من محطه المترو ولكن
حركه المرور في سطحي الساحه التي تسمى
بساحه شومان حيث مقررات الاتحاد الاوروبي
حركه المرور عاديه والسؤلفت من دون تواجد
امني اكثر مكثف بنسبه للدوافع لا نعلم
الان الشاب الذي يعتقلوا يشتبه في انه قد
يكون في العشريات من العمر ولكن لا نعلم
فما هي الدوافع التي جعلتني
هل تم تحديد هويه منفذ هذا الهجوم
الرسميه عن عن هويه الشاب او عن تفاصيله
او عن عمري ولكن من خلال السور التي نراها
يبدو ان الشاب في العشريه من عمره وتمت
السيطره عليه بكل سهوله من قبل اثنين من
رجال الامن من حيث التوقيت
اي تفاصيل او تطورات بهذا الموضوع سنعود
اليك نور الدين شكرا لك نريد مراسل
العربيه حدثنا من بريكسال
[موسيقى]
الى الملف الايراني حيث قال المبعوث
الامريكيه الخاص الى طهران روبرت مالي في
مقابله مع اذاعه بي بي سي ان واشنطن لن
تتردد باتخاذ اي خطوه لوقف سلوكي ايران
العدوانيه اذا فشل الحوار كما اضافا مالي
الخيار العسكري مع ايران مطروح اذا فشل
الخيار الدبلوماسيه وتحدث المبعوث
الامريكيه الخاص الى طهران عن ان ايران
قريبه من امتلاك ما يكفي من اليورانيوم
لصنع قنبله النوويه
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الجنرال ماركت مساعد
وزير الخارجيه الاسبق للشؤون العسكريه
والسياسيه امم جنرال يعني منذ يومين ونحن
نناقش هذه النقطه واشنطن دائما تقول
الخيار العسكري مطروح اذا فشل الحل
الدبلوماسي الحل الديبلوماسي لم ينفع على
مدى عقد من الزمن وايران على ابواب امتلاك
سلاح نووي ما الذي تنتظره واشنطن
ماوس
في هذه المره حتى هذه المرحله الدبلوماسيه
لم تنجح لكنها لم تنتهي
واعتقده بانه يشعر بان الوضع العسكري او
تهديدات الامنيه تعد كبيره للغايه الامر
الذي يدفع لوقف المسار الدبلوماسيه
هذا الامر
وفي الولايات المتحده
من هذا الامر ايضا واناس كثر داخل اسرائيل
وخاصه مع قدومي الجناح اليمين المتطرف
لسده السلطه وقد اعبر عن ذلك من خلال جمله
من التصريحات لكن الرساله هي ان
الدبلوماسيه لم تحرز تقدم لكنها لم تنتهي
او تتوفى بعد لدى كان قد
طيب تم تكليفي السيد مال لاعاده
الايرانيين لخطه العمل الشامل المشتركه
ان ايضا كان هناك حديث عن الطائرات بدون
طيار التي تعتبر السلاح المفضل ارسلتها
طهران الى اليمن بايدي الحوثيين ولعب
الدوله المحوريه في حرب بيظل بين ايران
واسرائيل بمناوراتها طبعا في سماء العراق
وسوريا ومع ذلك من المفارقات ان المخاطر
كانت اعلى داخل ايران نفسها
[موسيقى]
المسيرات الرخيصه سلاح ايران المفضل
ارسلتها طهران الى كل مكان حيث ميليشاتها
في سوريا والعراق واليمن ولعب دورا في حرب
الوكاله لتزيين الموقف وتهديد الممرات
المائيه لتنفيذ مشروعا الخاص
المسيرات الانتحاريه التي تجمعها ايران
تستخدمها كورقه ضغط لتحقيق مكاسب في
المفاوضات النوويه او لرفع العقوبات
[موسيقى]
لطالما كان الغرب يفكر باليه للحد من سلوك
ايران ومسيراتها وما حدث في اصفهان كان
رساله لتغيير في الاستراتيجيه
مسيرات من داخل البلاد تضرب موقع عسكريا
هذه المره في ايران وجود خلايا واختراق
داخل ايران مساله تتصاعد حيث كان البرنامج
النووي الايراني هدفا لمحاولات تخريب
متكرره في عام 2020 اغتيل كبير العلماء في
البلاد وتعرضت منشاه طنز النوويه لاضرار
الجزئيه وفي العام نفسه تم ضرب منشات
الكراج
مسيرات اصفهان ضربت مصنع اسلحه حكوميه
الايرانيه في وسط مدينه اصفهان والذي
تصادف ايضا ان يكون مركزا لانتاج مسيرات
يقال انها ترسل الى القوات الروسيه
باوكرانيا
تصريحات اوكرانيا لطهران بعد الهجوم باننا
حذرناكم ورد روسيا العنيف لادانه الهجوم
كلها اسباب تؤكد هذا التوجه وقبلها تحدث
اعلام امريكي عن ان اسرائيل هي من نفذت
الهجوم ومهما يكن من امر فانه جوما اصفهان
يشكل نقطه تحول في المواجهه بين الغرب
واطهران بنقل المواجهه الى داخله ايران
نفسها التي تواجه احتجاجات ضد النظام الذي
فقد الحاضنه الشعبيه له
اقعد اليك جنرال ماركت مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الاسبق للشؤون العسكريه
والسياسيه يعني اليوم موضوع المسيرات ليس
تفصيل بالنسبه للجانب الايراني خصوصا انه
اول سلاح بدا الايرانيين بتصنيعه خلال
الحرب الايرانيه
العراقيه او العراقيه الكويتيه حينها يعني
بدات ايضا ايران بتصنيع هذه الاسلحه وايضا
هي السلاح الاساسيه بحرب الظل بين
الامريكي بين الاسرائيليين والايرانيين
وبالتالي ضرب منشاه بالداخل الايراني ليست
تفصيل ماذا يعني ذلك
اعتقد
هو باننا سوف نرى المزيد من استخدام
المسيرات في انحاء العالم حيث اننا لم
نراها فقط في اليمن وفي ايران استخدام
المكثفا لها في اماكن متوتره مثل اوكرانيا
الامر الفريد في هذا بشان هذه المسيرات
انه يمكن من خلالها ارسال رساله بتكلفه
بسيطه وتحمل في طياتها عقوبه كبيره يبدو
بان بان اسرائيل تظهر رساله قوه امام
الايراني
ان نضع مسيراتنا في اي مكان نرغبه داخل
الاياران وهذه القدره تعد وقدره غير مكلفه
لدى الاستخبارات التي ترمي لاستخدام هذه
المسارات تحمل في طياتها اسرائيل رساله من
اسرائيل الى ايران بان نستطيع ان نقوم
بفعل ذلك الطائرات او الصواريخ او من خلال
خدمات الاستخبارات لذا ما نراه الان حسب
اعتقادي هو ان هذه الهجمات بالمسيرات التي
وقعت في اصفهان هي ليست الاولى من نوعها
التي هو وفقا لحساباته انها الخامسه من
نوعها وهي رساله واضحه توجه لمجموعه من
الحاضرين والجماهير اولهم
في ايران ومن الضروره ان ندرك ايضا ان هذه
الهجمات بالمسيرات قد ارسلت لدول ايضا مثل
الولايات المتحده لانه مره اخرى تقرير لم
تعلم بشانه الولايات المتحده يظهروا بان
اسرائيل العازمه على حمايه
امنها القومي دون البحث عن اي مثارات او
مباركه من الاخيره لدفع ان استخدام
المسيرات قد يكون وهو طريقه غير مكلفه
يرمى من خلالها ارسال رسائل اخرى
حول نوايا دوله ما دون ان تجعل الهدف يكون
باهظا في الانخراط في حرب طويله
بتكلفه قليله وفعليه كبيره شكرا لك جدولا
على هذه المداخله
بالرغم من تضارب المعلومات الذي يقال
اعداد الشاحنات المستهدفه في البوكمال
ومحتواها لكن الاجماع يتمثل بضربه
اسرائيليه اخرى ساخنه لايران خلال اقل من
ثمان 48 ساعه حيث استهدف الطائرات مسيره
قافله شاحنات في منطقه واقعه تحت سيطره
المليشيات الايرانيه في دير الزور شرقي
سوريا بعد عبورها من العراق ولم يتضح بعد
من يقف وراء هذا الهجوم العدد المرشح
المرشح للشاحنات المدره هي ست شاحنات من
اصل 25 استهدي فاتح بثلاث غراب بالمسيرات
والتي تقول مصادر سوريا انها اي الشاحنات
تحمل في الغالب اسلحه لامداد من اشياء
ايران كون تاثير الانفجار بعد الضربه
كبيره القافله كانت قادمه من ايران مرورا
بالعراق وبحمايه المليشيات المواليه
لايران كاحزب الله العراقيه وفقا للمصادر
السوريه
وعند توجه تلك القافله الى سوريا وعبورها
بحمايه الحدث الثوري ومليشيته هناك توقفت
الشاحنات في قريه الهري بالبكمال السوريه
وهناك تم استهدافها بالمسيرات واوضحت
المصادر ان الغاره الاولى كانت تحذيريه
لكن لم تصب اي شاحنه في ما استهدفت
الغارتان التاليتان تجمع تلك الشاحنات حيث
اصابت الصواريخ شاحنتين بشكل مباشر
واحترقت اربع شاحنات بشكل كامل وللتذكير
مشاهدينا معبر القائم يوصف بالممر
الايراني الذي يؤدي الى كل من لبنان
وسوريا يشهد كثافه عاليه بعمليات تهريب
الاسلحه وايضا البنيه التحذريه لانتاجها
وتجميعها على الاراضي اللبنانيه والسوريه
ورغم الاضرار التي لاحقت بما مسارات الممر
الجويه والبريه فهذه الضربات الجويه
المتكرره الا ان ايران لم تتخلى عنه
بتسهيل من ميليشيات الحجم وحزب الله
عراقيه من الجهه العراقيه طبعا وعلى
الجانب السوري تستلم التغطيه عشرات
الميليشيات السابعه للحارس الثوري والتي
تتخذ من البكمال ودرزور مركزا لها
[موسيقى]
في ملف موازن ايضا انه متعلق بالحلبه
باوكرانيا نقلت وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه عن
مسؤول قوله ان تاكيد اكتياب على تهديد امن
ايران يمكن ان يشكل منطلقا لتغيير مواقف
طهران من الحرب اعلق المسؤول ايرانيه على
تصريحات مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الذي قال
انفجارات اصفهان لها طلب الحرب في بلاده
واضف المسؤول الايراني ان بلاده ستتبنى
نهجا جديدا يتناسب مع حكومه كياب اذا لم
تصحح مواصفها بالتصريحات العدائيه ضد
طهران وانا طهران ستلجا الى ردود فعل
مختلفه
اكد المستشار الالماني والفوز ان بلاده لن
تسمح بتحول الحرفي اوكرانيا الى صراع
بيدروسيا وحلف شمال الاطلسي وذلك بعد
لقائه رئيس تشيلي في اطار جولاته في
امريكا اللاتينيه واضاف شولز انه بعد
التشاور مع رئيس الامريكي تشوبايدن اتفاق
على عدم ارسال قوات الى اوكرانيا تجنبا
لتصعيد الصراع
به دون خلق مزيد من الحرب ربما تكون
الدوافع السياسيه المحليه في المقدمه بدلا
من دعم اوكرانيا عندما يتعلق الامر بملفات
كالاسلحه يجب ان يكون الامر متعلقا بقضايا
واقعيه اسمحوا لي ان اذكركم مره اخرى انه
في بدايه الحرب استبعدت مع رئيس الامريكي
مناطق حضري الطيران لان ذلك كان سيؤدي الى
تصعيد مباشر للحرب بين روسيا وحلف في شمال
الاطلسي كما رفضنا على سبيل المثال
الطلبات غير المنطقيه مثل القوات البريه
وبالتالي مره اخرى لقد تحدثنا في كل شيء
بدوره هي قال رئيس كرواتيا انه يعارض
ارسال اي اسلحه الى اوكرانيا او لان ذلك
يؤدي فقط الى اطاله امد الحرب بعروسيا
واضاف رئيس كرواتيا ان روسيا للدوله خطره
ويجب التعامل على هذا الاساس مشيرا الى ان
شبه جزيره القرم لن تعود ابدا الى
اوكرانيا
اما ميداننا لا تزال المعارك محتدمه في
القرى المجاوره لمدينه بخمه الرئيسيه حيث
تواصل القوات الروسيه تقدمها بعد السيطره
على بلده شمال مدينه صيدا وذلك في سعيها
للسيطره على مدينه سيريس شمال باخموت
وتطويق المقاتلين الروس لبلده كراش
وقطعوا الامدادات الاوكرانيه من الناحيه
الشماليه عن بخمول كما هاجرت القوات
الروسيه مدينه بليغرفكا جنوب غرب في
مقاطعه لوغانس من جهاتها استهدفت القوات
الاوكرانيه منطقه في مدينه الشباس غرب
صاروخين هيمارس
معارك ساخنه ومستعره في المحور الشمالي من
مقاطعه دانيس حيث مازالت قوات تطوق مدينه
باخبط من النواحي الشماليه والجنوبيه
والشرقيه وتحاول اقتحام المدينه من المحور
الجنوبي قتال شوارع في ذلك المحور بالفعل
تشير مصادر ايضا الى استقدام الجيش
الاوكراني لاعداد كبيره من الجنود
والاليات العسكريه وتاسيس قاعده عسكريه
غرب مدينه باخبط في منطقه او مدينه تدعى
ساسوبيار ايضا هناك نفيه من الجيش
الاوكراني الانسحاب من مدينه
بلاجاباتنا شمال المقاطعه حيث اعلنت قوات
بان سيطرتها على هذه البلده معارك ساخنه
وضاريه في المحور الناري المثلث الناري
بينسك حيث الهجمات المتبادله ما بين
الجيشين الاوكراني والروسي وتشير المصادر
الى استقدام حشود كبيره من الجيش
الاوكراني واليات في ذلك المحور من اجل
التقدم حيث تمركز الجيش الروسي
عشرات المدنيين الذين انضموا لمجموعه
فاكنار في يوليو انتهت صلاحيه عقودهم التي
تبلغ مدتها سته اشهر وبداوا بالعوده
لبلدهم فوفقا نيويورك تايمز الاف المدنين
قتلوا في المعارك خلال ايام او حتى بعد
ساعات من وصولهم الى الجبهه لكن عشرات
الناجين من الوحدات الهجوميه سيعدون هذا
الشهر الى روسيا بميداليات ومدفعات كبيره
ووثائق يزعم رئيس بعد انها تمنعهم الحريه
وهنا يواجه المجتمع الروسي تحدي اعاده دمج
الالاف من الرجال المصابين بصدامات
النفسيه والمدربين عسكريا فضلا عن قله فرص
العمل اساسا هذا السياسه باعاده بعض
المجرمين الى ديارهم مع عفوا رئاسي حذر
منها خبراء لمخاطراتها باثاره مزيد من
العنف في جميع انحاء المجتمع الروسي
[موسيقى]
رغم عدم مضيف ثلاثه اسابيع على تعيينه الا
ان جعبه قائد القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
تفيض بالقواعد الجديده
مرهقه لاعداد التقارير على العسكريين
الروس الذين انتقدوا تكتيكاته
واستراتيجياته وتشمل القواعد ارتداء
السطورات الزرقاء الواقيه من الرصاص
الخاصه بالصحافه والالتزام بقواعد
التضامين الصارمه المدونين العسكريون
الروس وصفوا قواعد التقارير الجديده
بمحاوله تقويم هؤلاء يتبعهم ملايين
الاشخاص الذين يبحثون عن معلومات اكثر دقه
مما تقدمه
الدعائيه التشديد على العمليه العسكريه او
قادتها ليس من جديد حيث تواجه الشاب
الروسيه
وتبلغ من العمر 19 عاما عقوبه السجن
لسنوات بتهمه تشويه سمعه الجيش الروسي
كرتون بريطانيه سبق موافقه لندن على ارسال
دبابات تشالنجر 2 اوكرانيا والشرط هو منع
السلاح القوات الروسيه على هذه الدبابات
عبر تقييد استخدامها من قبل الجيش
الاوكراني حيث يسعى كبار الضباط في القوات
المسلحه البريطانيه مع مدراهم الاوكرانيين
لتجنب نشر دباباتهم من طراز تشالنجر 2 في
المناطق المصنفه بالخطره وفقا صحف
بريطانيه واقترح الضباط مجموعه خيارات في
حال اصابه او تعطل تشالنجر في الساحات
المعركه ففي حال تم تدمير خزان او تعطيله
الخيار الاول يتمثل دائما بمحاوله
الاسترداد الذاتي القيام دبابه اخرى
بسحبها او استخدام مدرعه اصلاح ومركبه
اصلاح مدرعه متخصصه واظن الخيارات ايضا
وجود مرتزقه على حبه الاستعداد لاستعاده
الدبابات المتضرره هذا واكدت هنا مصادر
بريطانيه ان الروس بحاجه للاستلاء على
تشالنجر ولو جزئيا للدعايه اولا ولتحصيل
اسرارها ثانيا لاسيما ان بريطانيا لطالما
تباهت بسجلها شبه المثالي مع دبابات
تشالنجر شهدت تدمير ثلاث دبابات من هذا
الطراز فقط علما بان بريطانيا تمتلك حوالي
227 دبابه تشالنجر في مخزونها 60 منها فقط
في حاله يمكن نشرها وفقارير
[موسيقى]
التاسعه المستمره فيها بعد قليل
16 عنوان توتر الجديد محتمل بين انقره
واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد استكمل المشاهدين
التاسعه بتذكير مره اخرى بالخبر من
بريكسال حيث اعلن الشرطه البلجيكيه اصابه
شخص بجروح بالسكين بعد هجوم في محطه لمترو
الانفاق في بروكسيل كما اعلنت الشرطه انها
اعتقلت المشتبه به ولا تزال تبحث في
الدواسه
[موسيقى]
استمرار
بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين شدد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي على ان حل الدولتان هو
الحل الامثل لانهاء الازمه مضيفا خلال
مؤتمر صحفي مع نتنياهو ان عدم المضيف في
حاله دولتين سيضر بامن اسرائيل مستقبلا
وعن على الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين اتخاذ
خطوات فوريه للحد من التصعيد
لانها مسؤوليه الجانبين وفقا لبنك
اسرائيل على اسرائيل
شيطان على سياسه المشتركه لمنع حصول ايران
بالسلاح النووي وقال انه سيفعل ماب ويسعه
لمنع طهران من حيازه سلاح
النوويها اننا نتوافق مع امريكا على سياسه
مشتركه تمنعها حصول ايران على سلاح النووي
وهناك اجماع على ان النظام الايراني لا
ينبغي ان يحوز السلاح النووي
ايران من الحصول على سلاح النووي وسنقوم
في كل ما في وسعينا لتحقيق ذلك
سافعل كل شيء لمنع ايران من حيازه اسلحه
النوويه وكل الاسرائيليين على علم بحجم
الدعم الامريكي لمنظومه الدفاعيه
الحديث اكثر عن هذه الزياره وعن رده فعل
الفلسطينيه على كل التصريحات الاسرائيليه
والامريكيه في ينضم الينا من رام الله عبد
الحفيظ جعوان مراس العربيه ومن القدس
ناديه البلبيسي مفردات العربيه سابدا معك
ناديه اختصار المواقف الامريكيه
والاسرائيليه بموضوع الصراع الفلسطيني
الاسرائيلي وطبعا الموضوع الايراني
الاسرائيلي
اهلا بك ليال اعتقد بان الموقف الامريكي
بالتحديد كان يركز على ثلاث محاور ربما
تحدث عنها وزير الخارجيه قبل قليل في
الوقايه مع نتنياهو اكد عليها مره اخرى في
لقائه مع وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي والان
ونحن نتحدث طبعا مع الرئيس الاسرائيلي
الذي يلتقيه قبل قليل هذه المحاور بالدرجه
الاولى هو الامريكيون قلقون من تدهور
الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه يريدون
بالفعل من اسرائيل ومن السلطه وهذه
الرساله التي ستواجه للرئيس عباس غدا في
رام الله هو وقف التصعيد والحفاظ على نوع
من التهدئه هم يعرفون بانه هذا يعني بان
هذه الخطوات ستكون كافيه لكن يجب ان تكون
هناك ارضيه على الاقل حتى يمكن للولايات
المتحده ان تعمل من خلالها هذا ايضا لا
يعني بانه هناك مبادره امريكيه او تفعيل
للمفاوضات بين اسرائيل وبين الفلسطينيين
لكن على الاقل يجب ان يكون هناك بعض
الاجراءات من وجهه النظر الامريكيه يمكن
ان الطرفان ان يطرحها على الطاوله يمكن ان
تؤدي على الاقل الى تهدئه وطبعا هذه
التهدئه تاخذنا الى المحور الاخر الذي ركز
عليه بريك في هذه الزياره وايضا نتنياهو
هو توسيع اتفاقيه ابراهيم لتضم دول عربيه
اخرى لكن سيكون الوضع الصعب لاي دوله
عربيه بان تطبع مع اسرائيل طالما الوضع في
الضفه الغربيه على ما هو الحال وطبعا هناك
عنف وعنف مضاد وهناك قتلى فلسطينيين على
مدى هذا الشهر هو الاعلى في الواقع والملف
الاخير هو طبعا الاول بالنسبه لنهايه
وربته بحرب اوكرانيا بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده وهو الملف الايراني طبعا الاداره
توافق اسرائيل على انها لن تسمح لايران
بامتلاك سلاح نووي وهذا موقف ثابت للاداره
الامريكيه احد الاسئله التي وجهت الى
البنك بالامس لكن ايضا بنك الرابطها في
موضوع اوكرانيا وخطر ايران ليس فقط من
خلال دعم الوكلاء في المنطقه لكن ايضا من
خلال امداد همم روسيا بالمسيرات التي تقتل
المدنيين في اوكرانيا لكن كما تعرفين
العلاقه بين نتنياهو وبين الاداره
الديمقراطيه هي ليست بنفس الدفء الذي تمتع
فيه في في وقت طبعا عهد الرئيس ترامب لكن
على كل الاحوال هناك قواسم مشتركه وهناك
حرز امريكا على الاقل على الحفاظ على
التهدئه من خلال وجود وزير الخارجيه في
القدس وغدا في رام الله نعم سانتقل الى
الزميل عبد الحفيظ جعوان مراسل العربيه من
رام الله عبد الحفيظ يعني امام التشريد
الامريكي على الموقف المعروف من من الصراع
الفلسطيني وهو منطق حل الدولتين كيف تلقف
الفلسطينيون هناك والسلطات هذا الموقف بظل
كل التصعيد الموجود على الارض
بالنسبه للفلسطينيين لم يعد كافي ان هذا
الموقف وخصوصا ان زياره بلانك انت تاتي
بعد يوم واحد من زياره مدير وكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه ويليام بيرز الذي
كان يوم امس في رام الله والتقى مع الرئيس
عباس وايضا مستشار الامن القومي سوليفان
كان في رام الله والتقى مع الرئيس عباس
هذا لا يكفي يريدون حلولا على الارض وايضا
يريدون اجراءات اصلا استعاده الثقه بين
السلطه الفلسطينيه وبين الاداره الامريكيه
ستطلب السلطه الفلسطينيه كما فهمنا من همم
لينكين على الاقل اعاده ما وعدت به همم
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه وهو اعاده فتح
القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه
والتي كانت قد اغلقت في العام 2019 في
اداره ترامب وايضا اعاده فتح مكاتب منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه في واشنطن هذه
الاجراءات على الاقل يعني قد تشعر
الفلسطينيين بان الاداره الامريكيه جاده
بالفعل بالمضيق قدما في موضوع خيار حل
الدوليتين والضغط على الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الامر المهم هي يعني اا الضغط على اسرائيل
لوقف الاجراءات احاديه الجانب والتي يعني
بدات منذ تولي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الحاليه زمام الامور يشعرون ان اسرائيل
يوميا هناك عمليات قتل عمليات هدم منازل
هناك تنكيل كبير في الاسرى في السجون هناك
عمليات انتقاميه من المستوطنين يشعرون ان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تتفرد في الفلسطينيين
في الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي ينتظر
الفلسطينيون وتنتظر السلطه الفلسطينيه من
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه ومن المسؤولين
الامريكيين الذين يصلون المنطقه ضغطا
حقيقيا على الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
وذلك يعني لتهدئه الامور والعوده ربما الى
مفاوضات او الى اجراءات بناء ثقه فيما بعد
ولكن يعني على المقلب الاخر طبعا همم
بالنسبه للضغوط الامريكيه التي يعني تطالب
السلطه في موضوع التهدئه السلطه
الفلسطينيه قالت
البارحه والسيفا انها لا تملك عصا سحريه
لم والتهدئه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه لا
يمكن للامن الفلسطيني ان يعني يثبت موضوع
التهدئه وينشر الامن في الضفه الغربيه
بينما هناك اقتحامات ليليه واجراءات
اسرائيليه من طرف واحد وبالتالي السلطه
الفلسطينيه تقول للاداره الامريكيه ولل
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه وستكون له ان
الامر كله هناك على الطرف الاخر عند
اسرائيل شكرا
[موسيقى]
توتر جديد عنوانهم مقاتلات اف 35 او اكثر
تي 5 قد يندلع لبن بدا وقد يتصاعد بين كل
من انقره واشنطن وفقا تحذيرات تركيا
الرئيس التركي اردوغان وجه رساله الى
الولايات المتحده مفادها اذا لم تلتزموا
بوعودكم حول وببايع انقره مقاتلات اف 16
واف 35 فعليكم دفع الثمن مشددا اي اردوغان
على ان بلاده دفعت للولايات المتحده واحد
فصل اربعه مليار دولار ثمان طائرات مقاتله
ولم تستلمها حتى الان بسبب المماطله
الامريكيه لكن ماذا عن سبب الغاء او تاجيل
تلك الصفقه حتى اشعار اخر بالرغم من انها
وقعت قبل سنوات الخلاف مشاهدينا بين
الولايات المتحده وتركيا والذي ادى الى
ازاله انقره من برنامج اف 35 بدا بعد ما
قررت انقره شراء انظمه الدفاع صاروخيه
روسيه روسيه صنع من طراز اس 400 ردا طبعا
على ذلك الغطوه واشنطن بيع طائرات لتركيا
وهي من طراز اف 35 في يوليو من العام 2019
معلله ذلك بانها قد تسرب اسرارا عسكريا
الى روسيا وتكمل تلك الاسرار بان المنظومه
الروسيه قد تكشف نقاط الضعف في طائرات
الاف 35 وتنقل البيانات الى موسكو
وبالتالي قدره الاخيره على مواجهه
المقاتلات الامريكيه وفي محاوله لتعديل
الموقف ولو قليلا اعلنت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الرئيس جو بايدن يعتقد انه
يجب على الولايات المتحده بيع تركيا
مقاتلات اف 16 بدل من 1,000 35 لتحديث
اسطولها الحالي لكن رغم ذلك لم يحدث اي
تحدد رسمي بشان هذا الامر قبل ذلك تواجه
الاداره الديمقراطيه الحاليه في الولايات
المتحده من نواب الديمقراطيين وج يرفضون
طبعا بيع الطائرات لتركيا وعلى راسهم
السيناتور الديمقراطيه رئيس لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ الذي اعلن مرارا
بانه لن يمارس صفقه الطائرات المقاتله
لتركيا سواء اف 35 او حتى مقاتلات اف 16
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الملف ينضم الينا من
واشنطن في اغاني مراسل العربيه امام هذه
الصوره التي شرحناها قبل قليل هل نحن امام
خطر الغاء هذه الصفقه مجددا مع تركيا او
على الاقل
الصفقه بتاع افسته عشر سوف تقدمها اداره
بيضا الى الكونجرس الامريكي ولكن كبار
زعماء مجلس اااه الشيوخ خصوصا رئيس لجنه
الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ مصمم على وقف هذه
الصفقه والسبب بحسب ما قال سنتر ان هناك
مشكله حقيقيه مع الرئيس التركي اردوغان
وطالب الرئيس التركي بان يلتزم بحقوق
الانسان ويطلق صراحه الصحفيين والسياسيين
الذين بحسب ما قال مندس هم سجناء سجناء
رايه وسجناء سياسيين بدون شك ان هناك نوع
من انقسام بين الحكومه الامريكيه
والكونغرس الامريكي تحاول الحكومه بيضا ان
تسلك الامور بقدر الامكان مع تركيا لانها
حليف استراتيجي ولكن الكونغرس الامريكي
لديه مشكله حقيقيه مع اردوغان ونحن نراها
امامنا نعم ابيير يعني امام هذا الواقع
تركيا بموقع الجغرافي بدوره السياسي في
المنطقه تعتبر منطقه استراتيجيه ودوله
استراتيجيه بالنسبه للروايات المتحده
واليوم بظل الحرب الروسيه ايضا لها اهميه
استراتيجيه اكبر بالتالي هل ممكن ان يكون
هناك حال سياسي قبل الانتخابات ام لا
انتخابات تركيا طبعا
كنا نتحدث عن الانتخابات التركيه طبعا
اعتقد انه لن يكون هناك اي حل قبل
الانتخابات التركيه الامريكيون يرون ان
هذا التصعيد الكلام من قبل الرئيس التركي
هو ماده انتخابيه همم
وهم ينتظرون انه بعد ان تنتهي هذه
الانتخابات يستطيعون التحدث الى الحكومه
التركيه بعقلانيه اكثر من الوصول الى
نتيجه افضل في قضيه الاف 16 وايضا ان
يتحدث الى اردوغان والحكومه التركيه حول
انضمام في فنلندا والسويد الى حلف همم
هناك الكثير من الاخذ والرد بين الطرفين
وربما تاخذ هذه المساله بعض الاسابيع الى
النصر الى النتيجه وربما نظر الى شهر سته
من هذا العام وتكون هناك نتائج افضل لان
الضغوطات السياسيه تكون قد زاحت من امام
الرئيس التركي ومن امام امريكيين ايضا
ايضا بياري يعني داخل الولايات المتحده
هناك نوع من المعارضه لاعطاء هكذا نوع من
المقاتلات للطرف التركي كيف يمكن يعني
اختصار هذه المعارضه اسباب ولماذا
[موسيقى]
بدات المشاكل بالاساس بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وتركيا خلال الفتره
الماضيه بسبب الرئيس التركي الذي اتهم
الامريكيين بانهم شاركوا في الانقلاب ضدهم
عده سنوات ثم رفضت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تقدم اشخاص اعتبرهم انهم من
المطلوبين وبالتالي بدا التصعيد من جهته
وبدات سوء هذه العلاقات بين تركيا
والامريكيين من جهه الاخرى ولكن كما ذكرت
تماما قبل قليل ما يحاول على امريكيون
فعله هو ان يوازنه بينها مسالتين المساله
الاولى هو انه صحيح انه هناك مشكله في
التعاطي مع الرئيس التركي ولكن التركي
تركيا هي دوله استراتيجيه ويريد
الامريكيون التعاطي مع هذه الدوله
استراتيجيه العضو في حلف ان ناتو بصرف
النظر عن من هو الرئيس في تركيا حتى الان
تمكنوا من ثلوج الكثير من الطرقات وتخطي
بعض الصعوبات تبدو الصوره وكان متوتره جدا
ولكن في العمق وخصوصا ما يحدث بين
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين والاتراك وايضا
بين العسكريين الاتراك والامريكيين هناك
الكثير من التقارب وهناك الكثير من العمل
لتخطي هذه المشاكل شكرا غانم مراسل
العربيه حدثنا من واشنطن
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الدفاع عدد ضحايا التفجير الانتحاري في
باكستان الى 61 قتيله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت فالمعارضه التركيه
عن ما سمته وثيقه السياسات المشتركه
لاداره مرحله ما بعد الانتخابات في حال
وصولها طبعا الى السلطه وتضمن الوثيقه
اعاده النظام البرلماني بدلا من النظام
الرئاسي المعمول به حاليا كما دعت الوثيقه
الى ان تكون مده ولايه الرئيس سبع سنوات
غير قابله للتجديد كما من المقرره ان تحصل
الوثيقه سلطه اغلاق الاحزاب السياسيه بيد
البرلمان هذا وتعهد التحالف الامه المعارض
في تركيا بتقليص سلطات الرئيس وتوسيع نطاق
الحقوق الديمقراطيه اذا فازوا في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التي اتفقنا اذا نجران
سياسه المشتركه التي تم اعدادها في مطابخ
الاحزاب السياسيه السته التي تشكل تحالف
الامه المعروفه ايضا
والتي تتضمن اهدافا ملموسه واصلاحات
وسياسات ومشاريعه ومن شانها اخراج بلدنا
من الازمه من اجل نظام برلماني متحرر
وديمقراطي وعادل يضمن الفصل بين السلطات
بدلا من هذا النظام الغريب الذي لا يعترف
باي
قواعدت السفاره الامريكيه في تركيا
في اسطنبول وذلك في ثاني تحذير من نوعه
خلال اربعه ايام وقالت السفاره في تحريرها
الجديد ان الهجمات التي تهدف للانتقام مع
عمليات حرق نسخ من المصحف الشريف في عدد
من الدول الاوروبيه قالت انها وشيكه
ومحتمله وت سيفر عن الهجمات قد تقع على
الارجح في مناطق يتردد عليها الغربيون بما
في ذلك منطقه تقسيط
[موسيقى]
تحدثت مصادر طبيه باكستانيه عن مقتل ما لا
يقل عن 61 شخصا واصابه 150 اخرين في
الانفجار الذي هز احد مساجد بشاور شمال
غربي باكستان وفق السلطات المحليه ونقلت
وكاله رويترز عن مصدر الطبي باكستاني قوله
ان معظم القتلى في انفجار المسجد من رجال
الشرطه وراس العربيه افاد بان الهجوم ناتج
عن عمليا انتحاريه وان اصابع لاتهام تشير
الى حركه طالبان باكستان التي اعلنت سابقا
سحابها من هدنه مع سلطات اسلام اباد
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من بيشاور عبد الرحمن
المزيني مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن يعني هل
من تفاصيل اضافيه حول هذا الهجوم خصوصا ان
يعني حركه طالبان باكستانيه تحدي الاساسي
اليوم للحكومه الباكستانيه
زار بشاور برفقه قائد الجيش
وقام بعياده ضحايا هذا الهجوم وطالبا من
السلطات الامنيه هنا والاجهزه الامنيه في
بشاور تقديم تقرير فوري حول ملابسات
الهجوم لا سيما وان الهجوم وقع في اكثر
المناطق حساسيه في مدينه بيشاور انا هنا
اقف على مدخل هذا ال- ال- الحي الذي يضم
مقر للشرطه وما بين سكنيه هذا ال- ال-
المنطقه التي فيها ايضا
بجوار هذا المكان هناك مقر لقائد بشاور
هناك ايضا مقارنه الاجهزه الاداريه
والامنيه التي تشرف على اداره اقليم خيبر
السؤال الذي يبحثه المحققون الباكستانيون
هو كيف استطاع هذا المهاجم من تخطي حاجزين
امنيين ودخول ايضا هذا الحي دون ان يت
عليه احد واا وهذا ما المح اليه وزير
الدفاع الباكستاني خواجا عاصم بانه لا
يستبعد ان يكون هناك مساعده تمت لهذا
المهاجم مكنته من دخول هذا الحي
وتفجير او تفجير حزامه النفس الناصف وصله
جموع المصلين همم
على هذا السياق ايضا السلطات الباكستانيه
عزت من اجراءاتها الامنيه في مختلفه المدن
الباكستانيه الاساسيه العاصمه اسلام اباد
تم نشر بعض من تعزيزات الشرطه على مداخل
العاصمه ونشر عدد من القناصه على اسطح
المباني الحساسه في العاصمه تحسبا من وقوع
احداث مناسبه عبد الرحمن يعني كان هناك
تقارير عده بالفتره الماضيه تتحدث عن
تنامي حركه همم طالبان باكستان على الحدود
وفي الداخل الباكستاني هل يمكن القول بان
باكستان اليوم دخلت مرحله الجديده وكيف
ستتعاطى الحكومه مع هذا الموضوع
نعم الحكومه تتعاطى بحذر شديد مع هذا
الملف همم هي لا توجه اصبع الاتهام الى
حكومه تكابل اود الاشاره هنا الى ان
السفاره الافغانيه والحكومه الافغانيه
نددت بهذا الهجوم واعتبرته عملا اجراميا
وهجوم الارهابيا يتنافى مع الاحكام
الشريعه الاسلاميه
وانه وقع في داخل احد همم المساجد لكن
السلطات الباكستانيه لطالما طالبت السلطات
في كابول بضروره ضبط الحدود ومنع تسلل
المسلحين من الاراضي الافغانيه الى
باكستان
وعدم توفير ملاذات امنه لحركه طالبان
باكستان وهو ما تنفيه الحكومه الافغانيه
التي تقوم بانها لا توفر هذه الملادات
الامنه وان مساله حركه طالبان باكستان
باتت مساله باكستانيه بحته وعلى اسامه باب
ايجاد حل لها لكن ما من شك ان هذا ال- ال-
الهجوم سيكون ايضا له ربما تداعيات على
همم لا اقول
تتيات سلبيه لكن لا شك ان الحكومه
الباكستانيه سوف تبحث هذا الملف مره اخرى
مع مع كابل
لمنع التكرار مثل هذه الهجمات انطلاقا من
الاراضي الافغانيه ان ثبت ان ال ال
المهاجمين تلقوا تدريبات او ربما تلقوا
دعما من خارج الحدود شكرا لك يا عبد
الرحمن المزاني مراسل العربيه حدثتنا من
باكستان
وفي سياق اخر قال وزير الخارجيه
الباكستانيه ان بلاده تقدر العلاقات مع
روسيا والولايات المتحده واوروبا بشكل
متساوي مؤكدا انها ستظل الصوت المؤيد
للسلام والحوار في المجتمع الدوليه
حتى بين القوه العظمى نحن نقدر علاقتنا مع
روسيا ولا نرى انها مستاءه من التطورات في
العلاقات الدوليه كما نقدر بشكل متساوي
علاقاتنا مع الولايات المتحده واوروبا
ستظل باكستان على الدوام صوتا مؤيدا
للسلام والدبلوماسيه في المجتمع الدولي
[موسيقى]
عقد ناصر بوريطه وزير الخارجيه المغربيه
اول محادثه ثنائيه دبلوماسيه مع عبد الله
باتيلي رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا فالمغرب اكد على استعداده للاستمرار
في دعم بعثه الامم المتحده في ليبيا
الزميل العادل والتفاصيل
رئيسي بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا
اعلن ناصر بوريطه وزير الخارجيه المغربي
ان الامم المتحده هي التي يمكنها حصريا
ايجاد حل في ليبيا بعيدا عن التدخلات
الاجنبيه
واحده ليبيا الوطنيه مع سيادتها الترابيه
حل ايه في اطار سياده ليبيا وحدتها
الترابيه
[موسيقى]
الاساسي
لرئيس بعثه الامم المتحده في ليبيا من
الرباط دعوه الى الليبيين من اجل الحوار
توقفت انجليزي امريكي
الليبيون يعبرون عن هذا بطريقه قويه
ويريدون مؤسسات مستقره وذات شرعيه تفتح
الطريقه امام الازدهار في بلدهم
على البقاء دائما على مسافه واحده من
الاطراف فيما ترى بعثه الامم المتحده
للدعم في ليبيا ان الشرعيه في هذا البلد
لا يمكن حلها الا عبر انتخابات رئاسيه
وبرلمانيه بعثته الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مع رئيسها الجديد تعتبر المغرب احد
الشركاء الدوليين في الملا في ليبيا فيما
الرباط ترى بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا مظله لما سارين اثنين يحتضنهما
المغرب حول الا الليبيه مسارس خيرات ومصار
بوزنيقه عادل الزبير العربيه الرباط
[موسيقى]
الهولنديه مجموعه قراصنه سبرانيين قالت
انهم مؤيدين لروسيا بشان هجوم الكتروني
على مركز طبي جامعي وافدت اذاعه ان او اس
الهولنديه بان الهجوم قد يؤثر على عمل
انظمه مستشفيات هولنديه اخرى وفي وقت سابق
نسبه وسائل الاعلام غربيه لمجموعه كلمه
التي تصف نفسها بانها الجيش الروسي
السابراني اعلانها عشان هو هجوم سبراني
واسع على البناء التحتيه الالمانيه بجانبه
وصف المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه دي متر
بيسكوف ربط جامعات همم القراصنه بروسيا
بالامر السخيف وافقاقه
[موسيقى]
قالت ريشه سوناتا الوزير ورئيس حزب
المحافظين ناظم الزهاوي لا تزال تثير ردود
فعل متعدده في بريطانيا
عن قراره مؤكدا انه جاء بعد تحقيق مستقل
خلص الى ان الزهاوي خلق قواعد وذاريه قال
حلفاء للزهراوي ان لديهم مخاوف من طريقه
اقالته هذا في مطالبه
بشان بكشف سوناك عن توقيت معرفته بوضع
زهاوي الضريبه
لم يحسم جدله اقاله الناظم الزهاوي من
منصبه في الحكومه ومن رئاسه حزب المحافظين
مع تعالي اصوات منتقده للاستعجال في فصله
من الحكومه واخرى معارضه للتاخير في فصله
من منصبه الوزاري رغم الوقائع ثابته
الاسئله تتزايد بشان طرد الزهاوي من
الحكومه بينما يتمسك ريش سوناك بانه تصرف
بشكل صحيح ونزيه بعد تحقيق مستقل في
ملابساته الضريبيه استغرق اسبوع فقط واخلص
الى ان الزهاوي خرق قواعد وزاريه
وما فعلته بمجرد علم بالقضيه هو تعيين شخص
مستقل للنظر في الامر
منصفا للتاكد من ان الحقائق
محددهم قال حلفاء لزهراوي ان لديهم خوف من
الطريقه التي جرى بها التحقيق والذي ادى
الى اقالته المعارضه وصلت توجيها سهام
انتقاداتها الى سوناك مطالبه بالكشف عن ما
كان يعرفه عن وضع هوي قبل تعيينه في
الحكومه في ما قضايا التنمر وتصرفات بعض
الوزاراء تلاحق مصداقيه ونزاهه سوناك التي
تعاهد بها لحظه اختياره مصطفى زارو
العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
حظرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من انا فيروس
يعتبر حاله طوارئ صحيه على عامه على
المستوى الدولي وقد عبرت المنظمه عن قلقها
من الخطر الذي مازال يشكله الفايروس على
حياه البشر
هذا وحضرت ايضا احدث تقارير الاتحاد
الدولي لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر من ان العالم يفتقر بشكل خطير
لمواجهه الاوبئه في المستقبل وافقه رويترز
على الرغم من ان كوفد نايتين قتل اشخاصا
اكثر بكثير من اي زلزال او جفاف او اعصار
في التاريخ ونبه الامين العام للاتحاد
الدولي للجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال
الاحمر من ان الجائحه القادمه قد تكون
قريبه للغايه كما دعى الدول الى تطوير
خطوطها للتاهب بحلول نهايه العالم
استمرار اعلان حاله الطوارئ الصحيه القصوى
العامه ذات الاهتمام الدولي قرار مفاجئ
جاء بعد الاستماع الرابع عشر للجهه
الطوارئ العالميه منذ بدايه الازمه
ومروري ثلاث سنوات من اعلان المرض حاله
صحيه طارئه ذات ابعاد عالميه
فقبيل الاجتماع الاخير اشار الرئيس منظمه
الصحه العالميه الى ان المرحله الطارئه
للوباء لم تنتهي بعد لاسباب عده
وارتفاع اعداد الوفيات كان من ابرز اسباب
استمرار حاله الطوارئ القصوى
لا يزال حاله طوارئ صحيه عالميه وانا
اوافق على ذلك مع دخولنا العام الرابع
للوباء ليس هناك شك في اننا في وضع افضل
بكثير الان مما كنا عليه قبل عام عندما
كانت موجه كوميكرون في ذروتها
منظمه الصحه العالميه كانت ابلغت الاسبوع
الماضي عما يقرب من 40 حاله وفاه معظمها
في الصين
استمرار الاصابات والوفيات بسبب كورونا
والمتحورات المرتبطه به جعلت الصحه
العالميه تتراجع عن رفع تصنيف الجائحه عن
الوباء
وابقت على حاله القلق العالمي سلطان
العربيه
المبعوث الى الامريكي الخاص بطهران مهددا
الخيار العسكري ضد ايران مطروح اذا فشل
المسار الدبلوماسيه
ايران ترد على تصريحات اوكرانيا من هجوم
اصفهان بانها ستغير موقفها من الحرب لصالح
روسيا
كونه اسرائيل
بلندر
9 10
[موسيقى]